it's using a false binary a choice which
is either the information we're told is
correct and is morally virtuous or to be
a questioner so the language I think is
very deliberate so the center for
countering digital hate for instance
we'll talk about musk in a recent story
as being you know effectively Pro hate
because if you're not anti-hate what are
you you're pro-hate so they create this
polarization there you're either with
the goodies or with the bad it's a false
dichotomy sure and in the case of say
climate change you know if you ask
questions you are a climate change
denier and it's not hard to see how
denyer is supposed to evoke Holocaust
denial which is something we mustn't be
guilty of so you don't put yourself in
that camp so there's a lot of smearing
by association yeah covert denies
another one